this is a production of Cornell
University hi my name is Karen long and
I'm a transfer junior at the school of
integrated plant sciences also known as
sips I'm mostly interested in saying
plant pathology and that interest
started in high school where I took many
agricultural classes including
horticulture and in my horticulture
class two graduate students at the New
York State agriculture Experiment
Station came in with rotting fruit and
vegies and diseased plants and they
taught my class how to identify common
diseases and plants and how to manage
them senior year I had the opportunity
of interning at the Experiment Station
with plant pathologist for a couple of
days and I ran basic tests like gel
electrophoresis I learned how to
sequence DNA and even inoculated beans
with white mold I talked to the plant
pathologists about why doing research is
important and they told me that they do
research to recommend disease management
practices for farmers and they're part
of the solution for food security and
ever since that day I've decided to
pursue a career in plant pathology I've
always wanted to come to Cornell
probably because my agriculture teachers
in alumni and I've done internship
that's the station and the researchers I
worked under are both professors at sips
and they've influenced my decision to
come study here but I went to Community
College first for two years
however my transition from Community
College to CIPS has been really smooth
and I appreciate how the Plant Sciences
program here includes
a wide array of concentrations like
Plant Pathology and the courses within
the concentrations can be very specific
like fungal genomics and as a plant
science student I'm able to take courses
in other concentrations like plant
genetics and breeding and sustainable
plant production also the faculty and
students here at sips are supportive and
collaborative and there's many research
opportunities here on campus so if
you're interested in
science I highly encourage you to see
what sips and Cornell has to offer
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu